I just recently got done reading YuYu
Haka show for the very first time and uh
why did no one warn me about the final
Arc I mean what happened like here I was
right still reeling from the insanity
that is yusuke being a demon Shadow the
Hedgehog with prison tattoos when all of
a sudden things are back to normal but
then yusuke is off to the demon realm to
find his apparently alive father but
also yusuke's dad dies and so yusuke
just starts a tournament instead as
voting Pro I I trial by comat I don't
know except we don't even really see any
of the tournament and one of the Demons
fights his son for the very first time
and then in the middle of yusuke's first
real fight we just fast forward to the
end and then there's some random
episodic stuff about a ray gun or
something and Gen Kai died off screen
and what was happening why why was no
one checking in on Togashi here I come
on